je sens l'âme coquine je sens le regard
coquin noël oui le sera dans l'esprit il
ya le podium des chansons il ya des
chances déjà parlé - pouvoir parler
parler oui bonsoir benjamin merci de
m'accueillir sur scène je sais le sosie
vocal de gims mais trinh duc de guise et
marvin attendait excusez moi vous me
tacler non on peut parler de la chaîne
est tournée drive
[Applaudissements]
alors tva l'alliance de ma femme qui est
accroché à la scène because grossesse
because gaulois je n'ai pas dire ça
voila voila c'est tout voilà merci donc
badiou oui oui et oui c'est ségou l'imsa
ont permis à william atteby williams
s'est concocté comme journée 1 2 3 je le
tue me demande
[Applaudissements]
j'ai raté le bus part à des choses et
vocal de johnny donc rappel et donc des
grands systèmes baptiste guégan il en a
il en a marre qu'on lui dise que c'est
le sosie vocal attend là où j'ai
commencé par jouer